hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast super selective primers
for the multiplex quantitation of rare
mutant sequences associated with cancer
presented by Fred creamer PhD we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots to
learn more about lab roots please visit
www.bucks com I am juni O'Rourke of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event this presentation has been
approved for continuing educational
credits if you want to obtain the
credits please click on me get your free
CMAC CME credits button located in the
lower left of your screen this will take
you to the continuing education page
where you can select a speaker click on
accme button and it will take you
through the process to obtain your
certification before you begin I would
like to remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
typing your question into the box that
appears on the screen will try to get to
as many as we can and will follow up if
we don't have time today also please
note that you will be in viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
finally if you have any trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know you're having
a problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce dr. Kramer who is a professor
of microbiology biochemistry and
molecular genetics at Rutgers University
dr. Kramer has been a principal
investigator at the Public Health
Research Institute for the past 29 years
he was on a faculty of the Department of
Genetics and development at Columbia
University College of Physicians and
Surgeons for 17 years and has been a
research professor an adjunct professor
in the Department of Michael
biology at new york university school of
medicine for the past 24 years please
join me in welcoming dr. Kramer I will
now turn the presentation over to him
okay thank you Judy for the introduction
uh let me start well let me put the
title of the talk on the screen it's
been a major goal of molecular
diagnostics to find a sensitive and
specific means of detecting and
quantifying DNA fragments that come from
rare cancer cells by virtue of a somatic
mutation that's present in those DNA
fragments the general problem though in
making an early detection of cancer is
that most of the DNA fragments in a
sample come from normal cells and so the
the problem that I'm going to be talking
about today is how can you selectively
identify and quantitate really rare
mutants fragments that are associated
with cancer there are multiple
advantages of being able to do this
let's say uh let's say that a patient
has been treated for cancer satta tumor
removed or crêpes of bone marrow
transplant after the treatment is done
there is still a chance that cancer
cells remain in that person's body this
is called the problem of minimal
residual disease and so to protect
patients who might still have cancer
cells in their body very strong drugs
are given which we are designed to kill
the remaining cancer cells the problem
is that these drugs are very toxic and
have serious side effects how much
better it would
be if there was a method after the
treatment of assessing the abundance of
those remaining cancer cells if any if
you had a sensitive method of that sort
you might not have to give these toxic
drugs I mean once you have such a method
clinical studies could be done to see it
at what level of remaining cells of the
body can handle it can can knock out the
remaining cells if you had a very
sensitive method a patient could be
followed regularly to see that those
rare cells are going down in abundance
and if they come up above a clinically
determined level then the person can be
been given drugs to help fight the
cancer but to do that you need a very
sensitive method there's another reason
to have a sensitive method of detecting
cancer cells early detection if a
patient is being treated with drugs for
cancer that they have we know that
further mutations can occur in cancer
cells that make them resistant to the
drugs right now you only become aware of
those mutations after the cells that
contain the mutation have become very
abundant it would be terrific if there
was a really extraordinarily sensitive
means of assessing the abundance of
cancer cells which are resistant to the
drugs that are being treated so that at
a very early stage you can change the
treatment regimen and put in a drug that
will work lastly people can be born
having inherited genes which give them a
propensity to develop cancer these
mutant genes like the BRCA genes aren't
aren't genes that cause cancer per se
but they are defective genes that are
are not good at repairing
other mutations that can occur
throughout the body so the other
mutations are the ones that cause cancer
in particular for instance if you
inherit the BRCA genes yessir you have a
strong propensity to develop ovarian
cancer or breast cancer if you are a
woman and right now if you do nothing
you only become aware that a cancer has
occurred in your body at a time when
there are substantial cancer cells that
is often too late and a person can die
from breast cancer or ovarian cancer so
many people have prophylactic breast
removal and removal of ovaries to
prevent their getting cancer because
they've been harriton me students how
much better it would be if there was an
extraordinarily sensitive method that
could detect the mutations that mean
that somewhere is in your body cells
have arisen cancer cells have arisen
that can call cause breast cancer across
ovarian cancer but the detection is so
early that then you can treat with drugs
effectively and this would mean that
people would not have to have surgical
removal of breasts and ovaries and and
these are just a few examples of having
a technique for the very early detection
of cancer would make a huge change in
people's lives the thing that has made
all of this even more exciting is that
there's a realization that cancer cells
when they occur divide rapidly but also
die rapidly through apoptosis or
necrosis and when a cancer cell dies the
the components of that cell which are
broken down and somatically end up in
blood plasma so the genes some of which
will bear the mutations characteristic
of cancer ah though genes the DNA of the
genes is digested into L
actively small fragments that end up in
them in the plasma of the blood stream
so there is now great interest in simply
taking a blood sample called the liquid
biopsy and looking for the mutations for
DNA fragments containing the mutations
that are characteristic of of cancer
these mutations can not only indicate
that cancer has occurred somewhere is in
the body the identity of which mutations
are there can determine the prognosis
for cancer what type of cancer it is can
determine whether metastases can occur
can identify which drugs are likely to
work against the cancer and so since
taking a blood sample is so much simpler
less intrusive than taking a physical
biopsy of say a lung or a liver taking a
liquid biopsy a blood sample is so much
more attractive however in the plasma in
the DNA fragments in the plasma are not
only fragments of cancer cells but
fragments of regular cells all
throughout the body normal cells and
there's far more DNA fragments from
normal cells than from cancer cells
especially if you want to have very very
early detection of cancer then the
cancers that the DNA fragments
containing mutation are going to be
extremely rare and there can be a
hundred thousand or a million times more
normal DNA fragments and and and
furthermore the only difference between
a normal DNA fragment and a DNA fragment
for a cancer cell is is quite often just
a single nucleotide polymorphism so the
challenge that our lab has been working
on
uh is to be able to develop methods that
can be used in clinical assays that will
selectively identify these very rare
mutations associated with cancer we
haven't done clinical assays we're only
developing the method but I want to talk
about that and the methods that we you
are developing utilize the polymerase
chain reaction larissa chain reaction
can I can take a DNA fragment from a
particular gene and amplify that
fragment millions if not billions of
fold so that you have a large number of
copies of the target gene fragment and
then using the copies you can identify
whether those copies contain mutation or
don't contain a mutation our approach is
to develop a means by which only the
mutant DNA fragments can serve as
templates for generating copies that the
normal DNA fragments cannot be amplified
cannot be copied exponentially and the
way we have what we have been doing is
developing specialized primers for
initiating the synthesis of the copies
of the target DNA and these primers are
designed to only initiate the copying of
DNA on a mutant and not on a normal
fragment even though the normal
fragments are much more abundant now let
me give you an idea of what the problem
is that we're facing here are two
conventional pcr assays in in this case
one essay the the one with a shown in
green is the amplification of 1 million
wild-type
molecules to begin with and there's a
primer in there a regular pcr primer
that's about 20 nucleotides long see a
little circle in the upper left-hand
corner of slide there that particular
nucleotide out of the 20 does not match
the wild-type but does match the mute so
as the second reaction that shown in
this slide is a separate reaction
started with 1 million mutant templates
and you see that gets amplified or so
and there's really no distinction
between the mutant amplification and the
wild-type amplification because whether
20 nucleotides of the primer bind to the
mutant template or 19 bind to the
wild-type template both primers of both
situations will cause there to be very
efficient amplification what what we've
done instead is we've designed a new
type of primer which is schematically
shown in the upper left-hand corner of
the slide and what it what this primer
does is it takes a normal primer say
20-24 Clea tides long serves two
functions one at the 60 degree
temperature of the annealing temperature
of the PCR reaction a conventional
primer is the dime to bind only to the
gene of interest that is anything that
doesn't have an almost perfect match to
those 20 nucleotides all the other genes
human genes are not likely to cause the
primer to bind to those templates then
the primer can only bind to almost
perfectly matched the proper target but
the primer a conventional primer also
serves to initiate
synthesis of the amplicon at its three
prime ends and what what we've done in
our laboratory is to separate those two
functions so let me use the little tool
here that I have if I can find it see I
don't see it in any case up the primer
is broken into two parts on the left is
a part that does seek out and bind to
the gene of interest but it's separated
by something shown by this half circle
from a much shorter little tremor client
which we call the foot and the foot is
designed to bind to the mutant template
but not to the wild-type template now
normally if you had a very small primer
say six or seven nucleotides along and
you used it hopefully only to bind to
the mutant and it will miss match the
wild-type at 60 degrees this little
little primer would hardly bind to
anything and if it had would have 20,000
different targets the human genome to
find so it wouldn't be specific but by
linking a the left-hand side of the
primer which seeks out the right gene to
a very short right-hand side of the
primer which is designed to only bind to
the mutants and separating those two
parts by that curved part then you get a
selective pcr primer so that this slide
shows the result of using such a primer
if we use if we have 1,000,000 newton
templates present you see you get us a
standard strong amplification of
1,000,000,000 target molecules that's
the red line but if instead you do a
parallel experiment with 1 million
wild-type templates or the only
difference between the mutant and the
wild-type is a single nucleotide
polymorphism there is a delay of
approximately 20 cycles of amplification
to to the 20
it's a million it's 11 million that's
likely to be amplified so that's
extraordinary so let me show you how
this works here is a schematic of the
operation of a super selective primer so
on the left side you see what happens if
the super selective primer shown in
purple binds to a target template the
long sequence on the left we call the
anchor sequence the curved purple
sequences the bridge sequence it's not
complimentary to the template strands so
you see there's a little curve in the
black template strands and then there's
this little foot that is only a few
nucleotides long and if you look at the
arrows if an interrogative nucleotide in
the foot the little G their binds is
complementary to the mutation the sea
then the foot will bind to the template
and the three prime ends of that foot
can be extended to begin the process of
amplification whereas if you look on the
right side if there's a wild-type
template contains an a instead of a seat
that G is not does not form a base pair
with an a that reduces the probability
significantly of the foot binding to the
template and it basically does not bind
an amplification does not occur ah
here's a more detailed look at a super
selective primer the red sequence is the
anchor sequence which binds to the
selectively binds to the gene of
interest at the 60 degree in healing
temperature the blue arched sequence is
the artificial bridge sequence which is
not related to the template at all and
it's designed not to bind to the
corresponding section of the template
fragment and then in green on the right
is the foot sequence with the
interrogating
side of the next to the last position of
the foot the pcr conditions are quite
normal they're shown below also on this
slide we have a code that shows the
structure of the primer it's written in
blue just below to anchor 24 14 / 14 5
11 that means that the anchor sequence
is twenty four nucleotides long the
bridge sequence in the primer is
fourteen nucleotides long and the
corresponding segment of the template
called the intervening sequence to which
the bridge does not bind but it
separates the place where the anchor
primer binds to the template and where
the foot potentially combines of it
simply so the result is that if you use
a primer like this and it finds a mutant
target there are really two hybrids
there's a 24 long hybrid where the
anchor part of the primer binds to the
template and there's I in this case a
seven long hybrid where the foot binds
to the mutant template but in between
there's a bubble formed by the
artificial bridge sequence and I'll go
back and and formed by the intervening
sequence in the template which is the
black curved part ok here's something
very neat about using these artificial
super selective primers so this diagram
that you have on the screen shows what
happens when a super selective primer
does bind to a mutant template you can
see the bubble formed are those of red
on top black on the bottom bubble on the
top of the diagram of the three and foot
binding and that the foot will then be
extended that's the dotted line
generating an amplicon
in the next round of synthesis that is
after the resulting double-stranded
molecules are melted apart and the
temperatures brought back down to the
annealing temperature now that amplicon
which was generated which includes the
super selective primer sequence serves
as a template for a conventional reverse
primer linear reverse primer which is
shown in blue in the middle diagram and
during that next round of synthesis the
blue primer is extended by copying the
template to which it is bound that's the
dotted blue line but here's the neat
thing when the conventional reverse
primer copies the amplicon made a copies
the amplicon that includes the whole
sequence of the super selective primer
then the amplicon made in dotted blue
rinds there is a perfect copy of the
entire super selective primer sequence
so now if you go down to the diagram at
the bottom of this figure which is now
the third cycle of amplification you see
that super selective primer now is
completely complementary to that blue
amplicon and so the purpose of this
slide is to illustrate the point that
the Selective step whether amplicons get
made or not select the slept step of
copying mutant templates but not copying
wild-type templates that differ by only
a single nucleotide polymorphism occurs
only on the template molecules present
in the original sample being tested once
amplicon gets made by a super selective
primer then those amplicons are
exponentially amplified in the
conventional manner exponentially 248 16
32 64 every cycle of amplification
doubles the number that are
they are making many many copies of the
target so that's kind of neat so let me
show you how this works in practice this
shows an experiment that illustrates
illustrates the working of a super
selective primer let me say a little
something about how these model
experiments were generated first of all
we chose as a target DNA molecules
containing the EGFR mutation l 858 are
its sub mutation that's are related to
whether drugs will work or not work in
certain types of lung cancer it's kind
of irrelevant for the test what it
actually does so we prepared a plasmid
containing this mutant gene and we also
prepared plasmids containing the
wild-type gene that did not have the
mutation in it these plasmids were
digested with a restriction enzyme so it
creates fragment and DNA and similar to
the kind of fragments that we would
expect to find in in liquid biopsy in
plasma and then we carried out
experiments using different mixtures of
mutant and wild-type so let's take it
one at a time so oh yes and we detect
the amount of amplicons made with
something called cyber green sybr and
it's a small molecule that is not very
fluorescent but when double strands are
made by an amplicon being copied the
cyber green intercalate into the double
strands in amplicon and becomes brightly
fluorescence so on the y-axis is the
fluorescence of the cyber green and on
the x-axis is the number of thermal
cycles that have been completed so let's
look at each of these reactions there
are eight reactions show
here the blue reaction is a control it's
just everything's there except for there
was no template DNA at all you see
nothing nothing happens no primer dimers
nothing false the green result shows a
reaction initiated with 1 million
wild-type templates and it is suppressed
so much that the signal only begins to
appear above background after the 40th
cycle a thermal cycle has been completed
then there are six samples all of which
do contain 1 million wild-type template
molecules but different numbers of
mutant template molecules what you see
is every sample that contains mutant
molecules in addition to outside comes
up sooner it comes up sooner because the
mutant molecules are copied fairly
efficiently by the super selective
primers whereas the wild-type molecules
are not moreover you can see that the
more mutant molecules you start out with
the sooner you reach an amount that
comes up above the background this is a
very important principle that these are
real-time pcr assays and the way that
they're analyzed is as follows the
dotted line shows you sort of an amount
above background and the machines this
spectral fluorometric thermal cyclers
that carry out PCR assays have computer
programs that can analyze these real
time curves and identify at what cycle a
significant number of amplicons are made
that's called a threshold psycho learn
or CT and so that where each of these
real time curves crosses that dotted
line if you look down from that cross
that's the threshold cycle and there is
a really neat relationship
between threshold cycle and how many
target molecules were present and this
is it it turns out that if you plot the
threshold cycle on the y-axis and you
plot the logarithm of the number of
Newton templates on the x-axis you get a
straight line and this relationship that
the threshold cycle that occurs in a PCR
assays inversely linearly proportional
to the log of the number of template
molecules in the original sample this
was introduced by our own laboratory in
1989 for exponential amplification
assets and it is the basis of real-time
pcr assays and assays that are designed
to detect how many target molecules are
present in a sample B now lized so you
can see that it's a pretty good straight
line is a small discrepancy seems down
log 1 that means only 10 molecules in
the presence of 1 million wild
technologists it's a little bit off from
the straight line and if we look a
little closer i'm going to add into this
plot the threshold cycle of the sample
that was pure 1 million wild-type
templates and you see that's it's only a
little above the threshold cycle that we
got with a mixture of million wild types
in 10 mutants so it's really possible
that the sort of earlier slightly
earlier CT of the sample with 10news was
actually caused by some of the wild-type
molecules generating amplicons okay so
we wanted to study the design of primers
so that we could get as perfectly a
straight line as possible being able to
clearly indicate even if you have as few
as 10 molecules in a million of mutant
10 molecules of the presence of
a million-mile types so these
experiments were all done with a 24 14
14 5 11 primer what the next the next
things i'm going to show you is what
happens if we change that 5 11 foot and
make it longer or shorter and so here's
the result if you make it longer see if
you look both at the real time plot end
at the log plot real problems arise when
there are only ten or a hundred
molecules of mutants the wild type is
not sufficiently suppressed with a
longer Flint on the other hand if you
make a shorter foot like 4 11 and the
log plots are shown here for three
different designs of super selective
primer the green results is the 611 foot
which wasn't very good the 511 original
one just a little bit off but the 411
really works best so the interesting
thing is when you have a 4 11 foot
you're really making a very small hybrid
a very weak hybrid and yet when you make
a week hybrid this would be six
nucleotides long oh although the getting
started happens later that's why there
is a higher CT for all of these samples
identical samples but using the 411
primer when you get that weak hybrid
there seems to be better discrimination
against the wild-type okay I also we
also studied the location of the
interrogating nucleotide on the reason
we put the interrogating nucleotide at
the next-to-last position is we assume
that if if a super selective primer
binds to the wild type and the
next-to-last nucleotide in the foot
doesn't bind to the template it's not
complementary so the corresponding
nucleotide in the template that the
terminal based
will also not be able to form so in the
case of this for 11 foot the mutants
would have a six long foot hybrid but
the wild-type would have a real for long
foot nitrogen so 4 vs 6 is probably more
discriminatory is more discriminatory
then say with the 611 Footwear you have
h vs 6 6 vs forrest greater ratio so we
did experiments putting that in
targeting nucleotide at different
positions within the same length 7
nucleotide one foot and and these
experiments in each case we ran two
reactions one initiated with 1 million
while types that's shown in green and in
the other 1 million mutants shown in red
and what you can see is the best results
occur when the interrogating nucleotide
is at three prime position or next to
the penultimate three prime position
okay we also investigated the effect of
changing the circumference of the bubble
if you may I mean there are two things
that determine whether a hybrid gets
formed one is the strength of the hybrid
it's in thermodynamics that's called the
enthalpy and the other is determined by
if the hybrid falls apart what's the
probability that the parts could come
back together again and and that
probability is called entropy and we
reasoned that the bigger the bubble the
greater they will actually the lower the
probability that the foot and the foot
target could get together and and so
here you see through the studies done
with three different sized bubbles the
one in green is bridge of ten and inter
I intervening sequence of ten the one in
red is 14 14 and the biggest bubble of
all is shown
blue and here again the bigger the
bubble the straighter the log plot but
the less likely it is for things to get
started the less likely it is for that
flute hybrid to form so the CT values
are higher and the last aspect in terms
of the design of the bubble is we asked
what happens if you change the symmetry
of the bubbles so in these five
experiments all of the bubbles have the
same circumference but in the upper left
the bridge sequence is 18 and the
intervening sequences 10 below that is a
16-12 and a perfectly symmetrical bubble
is 14 14 and going on to the right side
then we have a bigger intervening
sequence and a smaller bridge and and
finally a very small bridge of 10 but an
intervening sequence of 18 and what we
see is it does not matter all that
matters is in circumference of the
bubble not the symmetry of a level so
through these model experiments using
this one particular mutant target and it
happened to be a rather gc-rich target
for the foot to bind to we were able to
identify a key factors in making their
be better discrimination and and those
factors are have us a small foot have a
relatively big bubble click the
interrogating nucleotide at the three
prime end or next at the penultimate
position next to the three prime end but
it does not matter what the symmetry of
the bubble is so incorporating that all
together we made a super selective
primer that had a large bubble and a
small foot and you can see the beautiful
results that occurred so given a
particular target one can make
modifications and in designing a super
selective primer to get a very very
selective PCR reaction that will
give you amplicons from a mutant and
virtually ignore the wild-type question
then arose what happens if instead of
using plasma targets we use a DNA
fragments from the entire human genome
so this is basically a a repeat
situation except this time we had
wild-type DNA and we digested that with
the same restriction enzyme to get
fragments and we had mutant DNA which
comes from a particular cell line age
1975 that's the DNA was extracted and
also digested restriction digested and
so we could make samples containing
different amounts of mutant DNA in the
presence of DNA from 10,000 DNA
fragments from 10,000 wild-type cells
10,000 is more like genomic data what
you're likely to get and say a 10 ml
blood sample plasma from the 10 m / wood
sample and you see that we did very well
using a 24-14 14 5 11 primer and get
very good results so basically all the
fragments from the rest of the human
genome do not alter the results that you
get the super selective primers all that
matters is DNA fragments from the
mutation you're trying to identify and
quantitate however we tried a different
mutation b-raf v600e mutation another
one associated with cancer but this time
the target sequence for the foot of the
primer was 80 rich and we got very
beautiful results just using a sort of
14 14 bubble enna a 5 11 foot we didn't
have to go to the extremes for the Jesus
that we did with the gc-rich EGFR
mutation ah in fact we did it even one
further
using this particular target we tried 10
million wild-type copies and different
amounts of mutants and got a straight
line for the whole thing so what
distinguishes this mutation from the
ones we used before in the model
experiments it was the GC content of the
target with the b-raf be 600 e the
target sequences 80 rich means it's
making weaker hybrids so the general
thing here is the weaker the type of
hybrid that's made the better the
discrimination will come back to them
one more look is using a different kind
of mutation and egfr t790m mutation also
associated with cancer our colleagues in
a company molecular md prepared samples
that contained fragmented whole genomic
DNA from wild-type cells human cells and
also fragmented whole in DNA from a
mutant cells which contain the 790 M
mutation and they used these samples to
determine the number of g 7 9pm target
molecules any sample by droplet digital
PCR and we took the same sample same
volume and determine the CT value we got
for each of these samples and then we
put the results on a curve that compared
the digital PCR results to the super
selective PCR results and get a just
beautiful beautiful correlation it shows
that the CT values that we're getting
are truly representative of the number
of mutant target molecules that are that
are present ok what's going on here why
does this work it turns out I will go
into whole detail here but
thermodynamically the fact that uh the
foot hybrid shown on the right there
with the three prime symbol of the side
the difference between the probability
of forming a perfectly complementary
hybrid with the mutant and a mismatched
hybrid with the wild-type
thermodynamically cannot account for the
effect of million fold difference
between the wild-type in the mutants
there's something more going on and
what's going on and why it is that the
weakest kinds of hybrids gave the most
discriminatory results is that these
little foot hybrids that are formed
unlike anchor hybrids which once they
form last four minutes minutes on end
they just stay there these little bitty
hybrids at 60 degree annealing
temperature easily fall apart the mean
persistence time is less than a second
their lifetime is measured in
milliseconds and during the time that
they exist remember they're in solution
they're being knocked around by Brownian
motion they have to bump into a DNA
polymerase molecule that has to bind to
that foot hybrid so that once bound it
can generate an amplicon and it has to
do that binding before the hybrid
dissociates and it only has milliseconds
to do it and it turns out that the
mismatched hybrids made with the
wild-type because they're considerably
weaker thermodynamically in terms of
enthalpy then the perfectly
complementary foot hybrids made with the
wild-type their mean persistence time is
much much shorter in milliseconds then
the persistence time of the wild-type hi
Greta we don't know exactly what it is
but what we do know is they tend to form
a fall apart the mismatch one's much
before they have a chance to find the
DNA polymerase so you have two factors
determining whether an amplicon gets
made one is the relative abundance
perfectly complementary hybrids compared
to mismatched hybrids with wild-type
that are occur at equilibrium during the
kneeling stage but the second is because
these the perfectly complementary
hybrids persists for a longer time in
milliseconds then the weaker mismatched
hybrids of the wild-type they are
probability of encountering and binding
to DNA polymerase is lower so it's the
combination of both probabilities of how
much how abundant they are and how long
they exist that determines the great
suit selectivity of these primers and
and finally you remember that we noticed
you got better selectivity with a bigger
bubble bigger circumference and we
attribute this to the Brownian motion of
the solution pushes on that
single-stranded bubble and can actually
pull apart the foot hybrids and if those
forces are more likely to pull apart the
mismatched wild-type hybrid than they
are to pull apart the perfectly
complementary mutant hybrid so all these
factors contribute towards the
selectivity of these primers and and the
special aspect of these primers to
remember is their very poor primers they
form very very defeat form very very
weak hybrids and that's the key to the
selectivity now final it turns out it
turns out that the most informative
assays for assessing a cancer patient
our assays that are multiplex assays
that will we'll look look at different
mutations that are relevant to cancer
things that determine which drugs you
should use what their prognosis is how
abundant they are and many of these
mutations occur in the same gene so
there there are seven different key kay
rasa tations that occur in two adjacent
codons I mean these mutations may occur
in different cells but their location
is within the same or adjacent codons
same with egfr mutations and me Raph
that we were using but it turns out that
multiplex assays can be performed with
super selective primers and the way we
do that is we use another invention in
our layup called molecular beacons
molecular beacons are little probes the
probe sequences in die if you is in the
loop of that nucleic acid hairpin shown
in the slide and the probe sequence is
embedded within two arm sequences that
are unrelated to the probe sequence of
the target sequence but which caused the
probe to form this little hairpin and at
the ends of the hairpin there's a floor
for on a quencher and because the floor
for next to the quencher there's no
fluorescence but if the molecular beacon
is complementary to a target for
instance a target amplicon then it it
prefers to form a hybrid with the target
amplicon and the rigidity of that long
probe target hybrid causes the arms of
the molecular beacons separate also
separating the floor floor from the
quencher that gives you a bright
fluorescent signal so we can design
molecular beacons that bind to the
amplicons that are generated by super
selective primers and we can use
different molecular beacons for each of
the different amplicons made in a in a
multiplex super selective primer assay
and each of those different molecular
beacons will be labeled with a different
colored floor for so I want to finish up
by showing you our more recent multiplex
essays and so in this case we prepared
an assay which had two different super
selective primers for two different
mutants a one called Barack v600e which
we used before and knew one of B rafi
600r and in these assays we have
molecular beacons
in different colors quasar 670 was the
fluorophore for the beer at v600e and
flora seen was the floor for for me
roughly 600 are and we have two
different super selective primers and
just shows it works really well so what
you see here is that in the presence of
10,000 wild-type templates we put in
different numbers of beer a fee 600 our
templates and we get the usual spread of
CT values and yet the beer at v600e does
not interact the molecular beacon
doesn't direct amplicons aren't made
from the mute that's not present here's
the corresponding experiment where we
substitute we made different amounts of
beer at v600e but could in no b-raf p600
arm and here's experiment in which we
had both mutants present and wild-type
present this time a hundred thousand
wild-type templates and a hundred
thousand b-raf v600e mutants but
different numbers of beer fe 600 r news
and you see that the quasar 670 lights
up all one hundred thousand thousand six
hundred e ad exactly the same CT value
whereas separately the beer at v600 RS
the CT values reflect the number of
targets that are there and here is the
complementary experiment where we kept
the beer at v600 our constant at a
hundred thousand copies and put in
different numbers of you Fe 600 econ's
and you'll see that as controls
wild-type only even though there are
these complex multiplex reaction gave no
signal with either molecular beacon
that's the little line lines at the
bottom taking the results of these last
two slides just to show you that you get
really quantitative results here are the
log plots obtained with from those
assays so we are very excited by these
results we think that multiplex assays
can be developed to look at multiple
mutations perhaps even all seven or
eight different K res mutations that
occur in two codons each lit up by
different colored molecular beacons and
this will allow allow simple blood
samples to be taken and the DNA in the
plasma can be analyzed and a physician
can get a picture of which mutations or
present or absent and if they're present
what their relative numbers are and this
will allow business this will allow the
patient's situation to be evaluated
frequently because blood sample is
simple to take and therapy to be
adjusted and the whole purpose is to
convert cancer from an often fatal
disease to one which can be managed turn
it into a chronic disease to be managed
by frequently frequent blood assays that
indicate the situation and allow
changing therapy at an early stage
before there are clinical clinical
indications what needs to be done now is
clinical studies have to be done we have
to use clinical samples you have to
determine how much DNA there really is
in plasma samples on once you have good
assays you have to test it in real world
situations we haven't done that this is
just a method that can be applied but
it's so simple and direct the method it
uses pcr machines that are available for
everyone so I'll stop there let me see
if there are some questions that can be
answered let's see what we have it says
there are no questions available for
display that's a that seems good I'll
ask my colleagues ultra Marisol he's
gotten any questions but otherwise we
are pretty much there I will say this
that questions may arise later oh let me
well let me let me first tell you this
questions can be sent to me at this
email address and we will try and answer
all those questions as they occur later
so it's Fred Kramer at rutgers edu and
now I want to show you the people with
who did this work and my colleagues in
our laboratory this is Salvatore Maris
he is originally from the Netherlands we
have been together I don't know 16 and
17 years I forget that might not be
accurate long time here is Deanna Vargas
also been in our layup a long time she
is from the country of Colombia all the
actual experimental results I've shown
were carried out by Deanna and lastly
here is Sunday giaggi he and I have
shared a layup for 28 years and it's
been very productive and it's just
really been fun to do this work and the
fact that the work that we do which is
it's almost like art it's pleasurable
that it might have real clinical
advantages is just wonderful okay I
think that that's it I don't think we
have anything further and so we can you
can end the seminar there dr. Kramer we
we do have one question that's already
come in and I want to remind the
audience how to submit questions so I
want to thank you first for that
informative presentation so this time
for Q&A if you have a question you'd
like to ask dr. Kramer please do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button will answer as many as
we can so let's get started our first
question is how are these kinds of rare
mutations initially identified
I hope I can be hurt ah good I do not
know how they're identified we are not a
clinical lab I'm not a clinical person
we work with molecules almost like a
kindergarten we design molecules we're
interested in the nucleic acid
amplification the identity of the
mutations are provided by people who do
clinical studies analyze tissue taken
from actual cancers at different stages
taken from people who respond or don't
respond to drugs and try to correlate
with the mutations that are present when
they're metastases they look at the
metastasized tissue to see what is what
is there so the identity of the targets
is not in our area we start with
identified mutations but I think here is
the main thing no matter what the
identity of the mutation a super
selective primer can be designed to
selectively amplify just that mutation
even if the only difference between the
wild type of immune is a single
nucleotide polymorphism not only can it
be identified in a liquid biopsy sample
hopefully but it can be quantitated and
the relative abundance of the different
mutations should provide meaningful
clinical information for modifying
therapy personalized for each patient
and that could make a big change in
cancer and how we treat it that's my
answer
if there are no more questions I would
like to once again thank dr. Kramer for
his presentation do you have any final
comments dr. Kramer only that I okay
only that this approach using PCR
polymerase chain reaction since
instruments for carrying out PCR assays
are are present throughout the world
there are are tens of thousands of these
instruments and since these assays can
run on any of those instruments this
represents a much easier entry towards
getting information from patients on
alternative approaches it involves
sequencing the DNA fragments found in
plasma and done that's costly complex
there aren't as many instruments to do
it specialized lamps have to do it what
we're looking for is something so simple
that a sample can be taken inserted
perhaps into a disposable cassette
that's put in the instrument the
instrument runs the assayed computers
analyze the results and print the answer
on the screen so that a nurse can take a
sample and get an answer and not only
that the answer that is obtained the
computer programs can be built to
suggest appropriate therapy based on the
multiple mutant confirmed mutation
information that is observed so we're
looking for low cost simple assays that
can be carried out by unspecialized
people and it can be used worldwide
that's what that's why we're doing this
that's that's my final coming and I
thank all those that attended
thank you once again dr. Kramer just a
reminder if you wish to obtain me
credits for today's session please click
on the get your free cm ECE credits
button located in the lower left of your
screen this will take you to the
continuing education page where you can
select the speaker click on ACCME button
and be guided through the process to
obtain your certification before we go I
want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing for six months from today's live
event you will receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye